températures. Certains on les a
vu bronzer dans le parc, sa
fourmi et dans les rues de
Montréal. Voici mon reportage :
- Phénomène rare à Montréal,
les températures dépassent
les normales saisonnières
depuis deux semaines.
En plein après-midi de novembre,
le mercure grimpe même
à plus de 20 °C. La ville
reprend ses airs de printemps.
- C'est magnifique, on profite,
lade, on déjeune...
Enfin, voilà, c'est génial!
- C'est vrai que c'est très
agréable, j'en profite beaucoup.
- C'est vraiment très beau,
c'est super pour travailler.
- Sur ce vignoble,
le temps chaud est à l'inverse
source de stress.
- Parce que là, on voit
que clairement, les premiers
bourgeons sont stimulés.
- Thierry Kobloth possède
16 000 plants de vignes
à Saint-Bruno-de-Montarville.
Si la température dépasse encore
les 10° dans les deux prochains
jours, il va perdre sa récolte
de l'an prochain.
Avec cette chaleur, la sève
monte et fait sortir hâtivement
les premiers bourgeons
du printemps.
THIERRY KOBLOTH,
propriétaire du vignoble Kobloth
- Là, actuellement, si par
exemple on perd... je sais pas,
moi, une dizaine de bourgeons
par plant, la récolte va être
diminuée de moitié l'année
prochaine, ça, c'est sûr.
Donc, un impact direct au niveau
des revenus de l'entreprise.
- Depuis deux jours, il a cessé
de tailler les vignes pour
ne pas stimuler davantage
les bourgeons.
Resultat : il prend du retard
pour la préparation de
son vignoble pour l'hiver,
une première en 17 ans.
L'industrie des arbres de Noël
tourne aussi au ralenti :
la coupe des arbres doit être
suspendue quelques jours.
LARRY DOWNEY, copropriétaire
Sapinière et pépinière Downey
- La température est trop haute.
Normalement, il faut que ça gèle
un petit peu le matin, puis
jusqu'à 10 °C, c'est le temps
parfait pour coupe
- Mais pour l'instant, pas de
craintes selon lui : les arbres
seront quand même prêts à temps
pour décembre.
De telles tempéra
automne avaient été enregistrées
pour la dernière fois en 1938.
Environnement Canada prévoit
qu'elles redescendront
graduells la semaine
prochaine.
Ici Charlotte Dumoulin,
Radio-Canada, Mon